false information can be well deadly
Facebook chief operating officer sheryl
sandberg talked with us about her
company's efforts to stop it she also
told us about a new initiative to help
the global economy through the corona
virus pandemic yesterday Facebook
announced the company would give 100
million dollars to 30,000 small
businesses in more than 30 countries we
asked her why Facebook decided to step
in now these are unprecedented times
maybe the defining time of a century and
small businesses all around the world
are really struggling they're worried
that their doors are closing unable to
make payroll we announced today we're
gonna have 100 million dollars in grants
mostly cash and some ad credits on
Facebook is that what spurred it Sheryl
business is reaching out saying please
we need help yeah business is reaching
out directly and we're very close to
small businesses because you know so
many 140 million small businesses use
the Facebook platform I'm a small
business owner and I'm listening to you
and how do I get the money what do I
need to do well go to facebook.com slash
grants for business we're gonna ask you
to tell us about your business we're
gonna ask you tell us what your plans
are to weather the storm and how you're
gonna use this money and we're gonna try
to help I also heard that you all are
partnering with the w-h-o the World
Health Organization to make sure that
the information on Facebook is correct
what exactly does that mean what are you
all doing
well we want people to get accurate
information so from the beginning we've
been working with the WH o to take down
any harmful information debunk claims
that are false but also get their
information in front of people has there
been a lot of false information do you
think on your services that you thought
this was necessary well we're definitely
always vigilant but in this area we've
gone one step further and we're removing
things quickly if they're harmful I also
think there's a lot of information
people need they need information about
local school closings they need
information with local health
organizations but you know Cheryl I
think it opens it up to the question of
you want to make sure the information is
accurate about coronavirus
but people say when it comes to politics
Facebook sometimes knowingly leaves ads
up that they know we're not true why not
do that when it comes to the campaign
ads as well well I want to be really
clear for this crisis any fake
information is down it is down no matter
who the sources it can be a politician
it can be anyone if it's harmful and
it's fake it's down but but will you do
the same thing going forward about when
it comes to politic campaign 2020
removing false ads where's the policy
not changed on that well what we've
really done is made sure that anything
that's harmful can't be put on the site
in terms of regular content or groups or
ads when it comes to generalized
political speech whether that's in ads
or that we really think that as one
company being the arbiter of truth is
too much power and something that kind
of sounds like we should do it but as
soon as we started doing it everyone
would be like oh my god Facebook's
deciding what's true and false and
political speech is very heavily
scrutinized one politician says
something they've run it in an ad they
say it in the speech the person running
against them says it's false and that
process we think continues and needs the
full throated opportunities people have
do you have any cases of coronavirus at
facebook we do they're young they're
doing well so far from what I know um
how many cases do you have and how are
you all handling that we're protecting
people's privacy we're not announcing
our number of cases for me the employees
that have allowed me to know who they
are I've been indirectly in touch some
have wanted their privacy and I've
respected that and we're just doing
everything we can to help people in
addition to this project
noun Seng the 100 million dollars
Facebook is also doing something for its
own employees can you tell us about that
I just heard about this well taking care
of our employees is really important to
us so from the very beginning of this we
have made sure everyone got paid and
encouraged people to stay home if they
were sick we then went pretty
aggressively and pretty early to
recommending work from home we also gave
all of our full-time employees an extra
cash benefit of $1,000 and we've told
everyone everyone's gonna get their
bonus for this half we're actually
giving it a higher than the full bonus
we also feel very strongly about this
we're paying everyone we pay our
contractors we pay your employees
whether you're sick whether you're
healthy whether you can work whether
your job can go home or paying people
you know Cheryl there will be skeptics
there always are people who will say
listen Facebook is taking a beating in
public relations some of the press has
not been so flattering is this an
attempt to redeem yourself I think this
is an attempt to take the responsibility
we have and do everything we can and I
think this is a moment where everyone
needs to do that this is not about about
what will feel good this is about what
will make a difference and they know
that's going to make a huge difference
right you know she's hoping that other
companies will follow suit and of course
it's an individual decision but I
applaud them for stepping out early and
making a make they want to make a
difference and about the misinformation
they take that very very seriously
they're monitoring it they have they've
hired extra staff to monitor it they're
working with the w-h-o to make sure that
everything up there is factual she's in
San Francisco where she's sheltering
she's got two children no playdates no
interaction because they think they're
keeping themselves safe
another safe - it's great that they're
being so generous with their employees
there's so many exactly
that right now are in distress yeah I
agree I think we continue spotlight
companies that are doing the right thing
here putting capitalism side and
cooperate